are you an introvert or an extrovert
today we're gonna find out who's the
fake introvert I'm really excited to
watch this video because I find a lot of
times I talk to people and they're like
oh yeah I'm totally introverted I love
like sitting home and watching movie
I would consider myself both introvert
and extrovert yes that's a thing I feel
like you can tell sometimes when I make
videos with other people it's incredibly
awkward but sometimes I can do stuff on
stage and it's so epically natural
[Applause]
[Music]
six introvert one secret extrovert let's
freakin go you believe I'm gonna what
it's like discover supplier does already
passed right the life spies he or she
wins the entire fries I don't like how
they can lie but I guess that's the
point
silent round it's okay
oh so actually get to thanks me everyone
those introverts can't talk they cannot
communicate what are they saying here
that's so weird
I wonder how people react today you
really don't stereotype introvert also
you believe silent fun fact did you know
introvert can actually talk normally
likes okay let's watch what is he doing
it's making me uncomfortable
who's the surrogate this is what
introverts do all they put a bunch of
introverts in a room this is the result
I feel like that's a misconception where
at least in my experience I feel like
I'm comfortable with silence and a lot
of people aren't especially in America I
found that the conversations with
Americans are just like Bam Bam Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam and it's like oh I have to
fill the void with something to talk to
otherwise it's awkward but in reality I
don't think it is and I find that a lot
of times when people idolize mean like
podcast and suffer like them but oh so
awkward it was quiet for a second like
to me it's more awkward when you're
trying to force a conversation just my
opinion and also very boring I'd rather
be quiet okay this is making me angry
and we're only in halfway stylet rapping
[Music]
why is he not looking at her it's so
weird okay I guess we have to judge just
like base on appearance if I had to base
just some appearance she seems remote
introverted maybe these two as well I
don't know her I don't know
did you notice that notice these two
making eye contact she pull away right
away she's clear she's clear okay we had
to clear so far all right I want to see
more who if anyone else did they Hey
she's been cleared to actually I don't
know because I just felt like everybody
was like trying to look into my soul and
like determine if I was an introvert or
not okay so you guys voted the one in
the middle
interesting interesting all right fair
so they vote right away just based on
that what I really appreciate that what
is it called the nature a grasshopper
sound really two fully fully extend the
awkwardness all right so everyone thinks
ant won races physically or the way bike
mannerisms are I come off as an
extrovert
yeah expect it yeah he does seem bad I
think it's funny too because you put a
bunch of introverts
in a box and expect them to be like you
know taking people out and it's like nah
we're not you don't do that
did you know introverted people can talk
all right let's see it this is very what
I guys like to do my wing is her have
free time for yourselves I like to watch
tip talk take my dog to the dog park
stuff like that she likes to watch Nick
talk yeah she looks like the part at
least how does it make you an introvert
does it I don't think it does I feel
like she dressed up as hot this is how
an introvert looks like my energy and I
gain energy from having a long time and
being able to recharge
okay fair
there that's true go back to a place
where I can interact with people
no every time I'd like to paint
sometimes like go the beach or hike yeah
I really like running and hiking like
spending time in nature this is a bit
confusing because I feel like she's
she's speaking very extroverted Lee I
would say very I feel like someone that
goes on this show too high that they're
an introvert would not say something
like that you know what I mean they
wouldn't say something that would seem
more extroverted like going outside am i
right
they would be like oh I like to sit home
and yeah yeah well I look like watch now
she's clay also like writing as well
it's like kind of like my creative
outlet sure you're clear Alex next is
like chilli I just do watch like YouTube
videos what I'm not doing anything
see what I mean see what I mean that's
what a fake aim to it I just like to sit
home and I like a video game a bit my
didn't live and it hurts every time I
thought it'd be like nobody bothered me
nobody I'd knock on my door
yes my strategy going into the game was
just like maybe pick up on like the way
that people were like standing or like
just the way people held themselves and
they came across as more like confident
or more sure of themselves introverted
people can't be confident it's just
completely impossible
I guess it's such a broad thing everyone
is different at the end of the day
prefer like calling or like texting
people taxi come on what kind of
question is that of course everyone
listen introverted prefers texting you
can think of what you're gonna say and
tell me they're gonna call me I think I
did talk a lot at first because I was
trying to just say something so I wasn't
voted off too early what do you guys
think is like the heart
part of being an introvert meeting new
people like fair kind of opening myself
up
I've been let's go for like five years
my only friend is like my friend from
high school
so like didn't work yeah that seems
about accurate I can I can relate to
that meeting new people who has time for
that anyway let's get real here for me
like giving futures and like public
speaking oh my god a speech yesterday in
my class NACO haha no one likes public
speaking no one doesn't matter if you're
extra Verdean to hurt and while I'm like
oh I love to speak and run to these
people that no one lice who saw no I
just freaked out like for me it's like
in large group settings feeling
overlooked or like not considered since
I'm not immediately like vocal about all
my opinions and stuff something I'm
thinking about it and like composing my
thoughts and want to say stuff but you
know sometimes in those situations like
everyone talks over and then the moment
goes away I'm not like this but I know
other people that are introvert that I
told me that they feel like this so
she's safe safe so far I don't trust the
girl with the dirty jeans broken jeans
and the girl with the flower skirt those
two do not trust
it's a do we tie between Emma and Maya
wait seriously they vote out Emma after
she gave like the most perfect answer
about what you guys don't deserve money
introverts don't deserve money I'm gonna
say it
you know introvert these are poor
friendly and bubbly and that maybe you
came across as like outgoing so they may
be pinpointed me for that I can see that
I can see that are we starting you guys
ever done any like the personality test
well those are guys like that's a good
question what is that like the Advocate
yeah but it's turbulent in Sweden we
have a saying yesterday your glory
muslin it means I suspect owls in them
in the marsh and I'm like I'm expecting
a lot of house in the mosque right now
somebody's like talking about like I
ever I don't know the order I was
seriously clueless so I thought I was
gonna be out once they started doing
that so like what do you guys think you
struggle with the most with being like
an introvert like I was like miss
consumption yeah cause like that's what
I'm you know I don't know where it's I
would say for maybe they just assume not
like I hate people like I've been told a
lot that I seem intimidating at first
since I'm so like reserved and I have
like my show I like the reason I brought
it up is because like a lot of people
assume like I'm not confident I'm like
they're like oh you just need to be a
more outgoing and I'm like I'm really
confident myself like I Know Who I am
but that doesn't mean like I can't be
introverted at the same time okay that's
fair you like to complete her me yeah
everybody's on a spectrum
so they sure are well are in a hundred
percent in
or a hundred percent an extrovert we all
have like tendencies of both because no
I think that relates to me a world we're
like somebody's a hundred percent one
thing I actually do talk a lot like with
like my close friend like a family but
like outside like social public places I
like a more reserved
true-true that's a giving that's a given
determine factor I feel like extroverted
people cannot shut the f--- up about
around people they just met introverted
people only really talk when they they
know and aren't comfortable with someone
is that correct I feel like I'm correct
about that I'm basing all of this on
Americans basically because every time I
go in America every wants an extra to
feel safe like why is everyone talking
to me stop talking to me stop it maybe
I'm just your opinion it's such a
difference though you talk to a stranger
here it's like what what are you doing
we don't we don't do that you talk to
someone America I'll be like oh it was
strangers - I just like yeah yeah same
like I feel like I need my energy
it's my I'm sorry like you were saying
to think that like we're boring people
you know cuz we can have fun but it just
depends on who we're with so well that
means you're boring around people that
think that you are boring around doesn't
mean I'm really funny I swear I just
have fun with other people I'm not
boring I feel that I'm like really
emotional like with my close friends I
like let all of it out but then with
people I'm not what the hell is
happening it's starting red well okay
it's time to vote alright who would you
vote based on this be honest I will vote
flower same same I really think these
strongly that these three are safe these
two I don't know I would still vote her
I voted for Alex because I could see him
at a party like having fun he just kind
of had a bubbly
[Music]
introverts cannot have fun at parties
impossible I see what you mean but yeah
that sounds really funny introverts go
to party and they cry they cry every
time Dan they were too mad huh I'm like
surrounded by other introverts I'll
notice I'll be the ones that just kind
of like step up and talk more so I think
maybe people saw that I was being like
that was a little bit more comfortable
within the group so they kind of saw
that as maybe like an extrovert I
continue continue while the confidence
so Maya thinks for sure that she knows
everyone is out interesting
Thank You Dean how do you guys go about
dating it's hard I have a girlfriend but
we're both introverts and we're both
really independent we know like when to
give each other space like we know that
it doesn't mean that we don't care or
love each other less it just means like
we need a recharge like we don't have to
constantly talk all the time and like
really that's very that's very hard I
need to put myself out there more cuz
I'm like I want to date you know like I
want to find somebody but at the same
time it's just that like meeting up part
and like alright my you're a liar you're
a liar you're stinky liar potato liar
knock down yeah you know no I don't know
are you saying okay well I usually don't
approach people but like when I get
approached I kind of have about how to
like go scene or just like 20 minutes
before I'm like sorry I can't right I'm
going to right all right I swear I swear
liar I like being able to be to myself
and do what I want on my free time
without anybody getting offended of why
I don't want them around you know so
yeah truth truth I relate to this so
much I need my space
I don't know I really don't know someone
is a really good liar I work on that she
just seemed very calm to me
as for boasting everyone else they seem
more nervous and kind of anxious you
guys still with like anxiety did you
tonight guys not heard from Jake Paul
anxieties in real what do you say what
are you talking about do you guys have
like a method for anxiety like how to
calm down anxiety anxiety that's not how
you say it
learn to speak Maya go back to speaking
school I'm still looking for one okay I
have a really hard time like coming down
when I'm really anxious so it's like
hard for me because I shot down
completely like I can't talk or anything
when I'm really anxious so it's mostly
like just me sitting and like staring at
a wall yeah for me it's like music or
just kind of like deep breathing
yeah same like the way I go to sleep
because I have like insomnia like I
can't go to sleep and so like I'll play
like the meditation music on YouTube and
it kind of just like mellows me out
because I overthink a lot and that's
what keeps me up at night
there's nothing to do with introvert but
I feel like people with inner vert it's
like what I said about Kingdom Hearts
people with introvert cannot shut the up
about their anxiety I'm just kidding I'm
joking I'm joking that was too hard
they voted her out damn it look like I
guess I would have done the same out
there yeah yeah it's your life surround
that people would vote me off just off
of the first look but I was surprised
that I stayed so long
okay I think they're done vibes they
passed the vibe check okay all right
here's the moment of truth who is it
going to be I bet it was the first guy
they got him right away or something
what I mean
recent last round and losing was really
heartbreaking I was pretty upset because
I thought we had it I thought we had
them all out you're at Stinky's how can
you just lie like that
she's really good at lying
you sociopath she should be a defined
associate bad Jake okay I was like very
sincere about my answers like did you
feel that way about introverts like I
feel like I feel bad yeah yeah I'm 100%
on the extrovert side what I'm an ENFJ
my number one passion is communication
and like so she gives me like more
energy than anything like I could spend
every single day with some quick Wow
okay all right about being like an
introvert you typically think someone
who's God I need to go back to speak
school dammit sorry someone who's
generally like very quiet but what it
really means is that we as introverts
just get energy from ourselves like we
need to like if we need some space we
get that from reading a book or you know
watching some Netflix as they were
saying that's true that's true
I feel like I'm both though I can get
energy from other people as well I it's
just like if it's too much I get
overwhelmed and I don't like it I wanted
to represent more extroverted introverts
and show that like thank you Alex I feel
so much better about myself
finally there's no one else like me if
there's no one else like me then who
I well done for lying so well I mean
respite yeah I just like collect it do I
just collect it no leave it there
everybody Alex because I can seeing
having fun parties I love that comment
okay just because you're an introvert
doesn't mean you're not confident well
these people maybe integrate a lot of
them are are also socially awkward I'm
an introvert and I still like talking to
people having fun I just need some time
alone to recharge so maybe I'm just
awkward around people maybe that's my
issue maybe I got this whole thing wrong
what do you think leave thoughts down in
comments subscribe and hit the bell
button for videos every single day we
also now have the G fuel day cups a
shaker cups and they are available on
the link in the description and I see
you guys tomorrow
next week hey though hey hey you know
what big peepees do they play
PewDiePie's pixel ings of course pixel
ins is a creature collecting game I'm
the primary shareholder over a bazillion
players have downloaded and it's got a
perfect score it's safe to say it's the
most popular game of all time pretty pie
pixel aims it's awesome deal with it
build with it
you